KHERSON AREA ARE VERY MUCH ON
THE BACK FOOT.
>> MATTHEW CHANCE FOR US IN
MOSCOW, THANK YOU.
>>> THE STATE DEPARTMENT FOR ITS
PART IS CALLING RUSSIA'S
DEEPENING ALLIANCE WITH IRAN A
PROFOUND THREAT TO THE U.S. AND
TO THE WORLD.
CNN HAS LEARNED FROM TWO SOURCES
THAT IRANIANS ARE IN CRIMEA
TRAINING RUSSIAN MILITARY ON HOW
TO USE DRONES BUILT IN IRAN.
>> IT'S BELIEVED THAT HUNDREDS
OF THESE IRANIAN-MADE DRONES
HAVE BEEN LAUNCHED AGAINST
UKRAINIANS IN RUSSIA'S RENEWED
ASSAULT.
ONE SOURCE SAID THAT DOZENS OF
IRANIAN PERSONNEL HAVE BEEN SENT
TO CRIMEA AFTER RUSSIANS
EXPERIENCED NUMEROUS FAILURES IN
TESTING AND DEPLOYING THE
WEAPONS.
CNN HAS REACHED OUT TO THE
IRANIAN MISSION AT THE UNITED
NATIONS FOR A RESPONSE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT ALL OF THIS NOW
WITH RETIRED ARMY MAJOR GENERAL
JAMES SPIDER MARKS, A CNN
MILITARY ANALYST.
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
LET ME START HERE WITH THIS
DECLARATION OF MARTIAL LAW.
THESE FOUR AREAS, THEY ALREADY
HAVE RUSSIAN INSTALLED CIVILIAN
LEADERSHIP, THERE'S ALREADY A
STRONG RUSSIAN MILITARY PRESENCE
THERE.
HOW MUCH DOES THIS DECLARATION
CHANGE DAILY LIFE FOR THE
UKRAINIANS WHO ARE LIVING IN
THESE REGIONS?
>> VICTOR, I THINK IT CHANGES IT
VERY LITTLE.
LOOK, WE'VE SEEN THE RUSSIAN
FORCES HAVE DEMONSTRATED WHAT
THEY ARE CAPABLE OF DOING ON THE
GROUND.
I DON'T THINK THAT THIS
DECLARATION ALTERS ANY OF THAT.
I THINK WHAT REALLY PUTIN IS
DRYING TO DO WITH THIS
DECLARATION IS TO CREATE A
MILITARY ISOLATION ZONE, HE'S
LIMITED MOVEMENT WITHIN RUSSIA
ALONG THE BORDER AREA AND THEN
WITHIN THESE FOUR ANNEXED AREAS
OR AT LEAST HE'S DECLARED THAT
THEY ARE ANNEXED, CLEARLY
THEY'RE BEING CONTESTED, QUITE
EFFECTIVELY BEING CONTESTED IS
HE'S CREATING THIS ISOLATION
ZONE WHERE IT'S ALMOST LIKE
ANYTHING GOES.
LOOK, THERE ARE RULES THAT
GOVERN COMBAT, WE KNOW THAT IS
CORRECT THERE'S THE MORAL
APPLICATION OF FORCE, WE KNOW
THAT.
THE RUSSIANS DON'T ABIDE BY ANY
OF THIS AND SO I THINK THIS IS
PUTIN'S EFFORT, AGAIN, HIS
PRIMARY AUDIENCE IS A DOMESTIC
INTERNAL AUDIENCE AND HE IS
DECLARING THAT HE'S TRYING TO
MAKE IT CRYSTAL CLEAR THAT THIS
IS A MILITARY OPERATION, WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE EVERYBODY CAN MOVE
OFF THE STREETS, CAN HAVE THEIR
SAFE -- THEIR SAFE AND SECURITY
ZONES, BUT THE MILITARY IS GOING
TO BE CONDUCTING OPERATIONS.
THE WORLD -- THE EXTERNAL
AUDIENCE, THE WORLD UNDERSTANDS
THAT THIS IS NONSENSE AND WE'VE
BEEN SEEING THIS FOR QUITE SOME
TIME.
SO I THINK IT'S TRULY -- TRULY
AN EFFORT ON HIS PART TO TRY TO
WORK AS DOMESTIC AUDIENCE.
>> DOESN'T IT ALSO RAISE THE
QUESTION, THOUGH, OF WHETHER
PUTIN AND RUSSIA THE FORCES ON
THE GROUND ARE ACTUALLY HAVING
TROUBLE CONTROLLING THOSE AREAS.
IF THEY HAVE TO GO TO THIS STEP
WHAT DOES THAT REALLY STAY?
>> WELL, THEY HAVE A NEW
COMMANDER IN CHARGE, THE BUTCHER
IN SYRIA, HE'S NOW IN CHARGE IN
UKRAINE, HE IS TRULY A WORLD WAR
I BUTCHER WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT
TYPE OF WARFARE THAT HE HAS
CONDUCTED AND WHAT TOOK PLACE IN
SYRIA WHEN RUSSIAN FORCES WENT
INTO SYRIA AND BACKED THE ASSAD
REGIME.
IT'S COMPLETE BRUTALITY AND
CRIMINALITY AND WE ARE SEEING
THAT PLAYING OUT IN UKRAINE.
RUSSIA REALIZES ITS MILITARY IS
IN A VERY TOUGH SPOT BECAUSE
THEY'VE DEMONSTRATED THEIR
INCREDIBLE INCOMPETENCE.
IT'S EXPOSED TO THE WORLD AND
PRIMARILY IT'S EXPOSED TO XI
JINPING THAT CHINA WHO IS
WHISPERING, IF NOT WHISPERING
SPEAKING LOUDLY INTO PUTIN'S EAR
SAYING LET'S GET THIS THING OVER
WITH, THIS IS BAD FOR BUSINESS,
CHINA VIEWS THE WORLD THROUGH A
BUSINESS TRANSACTIONAL FILTER,
YOU ARE MAKING IT BAD FOR
BUSINESS LET'S GET THIS OVER
WITH AND DOUBLE DOWN.
HE'S ALSO SAYING DON'T PULL A
NUKE OUT BECAUSE THAT GETS
EVERYBODY INVOLVED IN IN MESS.
>> WHAT'S YOUR ASSESSMENT OF THE
UP TO 60,000 PEOPLE BEING
RELOCATED OUT OF THE KHERSON
REGION?
THE RUSSIANS ARE SAYING THAT
THIS IS AN EVACUATION TO PROTECT
THESE PEOPLE FROM SOME UKRAINIAN
ATTACK.
THERE'S NO INDICATION THAT THE
UKRAINIANS ARE ATTACKING THEIR
OWN PEOPLE, BUT WHAT DO YOU MAKE
OF THE RELOCATION AND THE
JUSTIFICATION?
>> YEAH, THE RELOCATION AND --
THE RELOCATION IS SIMPLY AN
EFFORT ON PUTIN'S PART TO REDUCE
THE POSSIBILITY OF
COLLABORATION, THAT'S THE WAY I
VIEW IT.
THE METHODOLOGY IS WHATEVER HE
WANTS TO MAKE OF IT.
AGAIN, THE NARRATIVE IS HE'S
DOING IT FOR THE PRO CONNECTION
OF THE CIVILIANS AND WE SEE THIS
FOR WHAT IT REALLY S HE WANTS TO
MOVE THESE FOLKS OUT OF THE WAY,
HE WANTS TO CONTINUE HIS BRUTAL
CAMPAIGN, HIS INDISCRIMINATE
APPLICATION OF FORCE.
IF THE CIVILIANS DON'T GET OUT
OF THE WAY THEY'RE GOING TO BE
CASUALTIES.
SO THERE I